woman a cop car dot oh my God this is
crazy dog
hey how you doing you all right come
here real quick
you're not in any trouble what the heck
come to the back
hey hey hold on I'll tell you what hey
what's going on
hey I'll tell you why good come on relax
get my phone is right right there right
there
go live
what did I do
bro
what did I I didn't do nothing though
hear me out you ready
you're gonna listen to me
something
yo bro oh my God bro
and we are going away
okay
that's what that is yeah it happened to
his boy Aiden last night okay so this is
one of those silliest things people yeah
oh and he didn't know his wife right I
don't know who he is right now I don't
care about it we don't care well I'm
just letting you know that's the
situation like that okay yeah that's
that's what it is someone called him in
you can look on what no I believe you I
I believe that that's what you think for
the past two hours
live doing what waiting for this to
happen no
breaking a PS4 he plays video games live
on stream like I said it's 100 000
people watching
right now
foreign
[Music]
Bell in the chat
they making us turn it off
but we'll keep going
that's his mom calling him
where's Dad's offering yeah
I'm just this cameraman that's all I am
but it was in Miami Heat same thing
happened to him last night that's
something going on right now they
swapped
the thing that people do they find that
his address oh somebody got killed doing
that where was that that was uh that's
why he's freaking out because he knows
the risk of it yeah that's so you're
saying somebody
oh I know called us yeah I know for sure
yeah and if you if you don't believe me
you can we literally just ended a live
stream you've been streaming for the
past three and a half hours two hours
two and a half three and a half hours
you can see everything he's done for the
past two and a half hours okay so
do me a favor you can walk out here with
us yeah leave yourself well here I'll
carry it for you
oh it's his phone
said that he was about to kill me
all right
do you know who he's here with uh
hello
yeah
there's a gun locked up and everything
is there anybody else inside okay
another kid out
who it is
as long as the guns aren't coming over
here so is he safe yeah
we'll go
are you dead or step dancer
what kind of cars do you drive
okay
she uh
yeah all right sounds good yeah we'll
talk to you there you go that was quick
coming in here
she is happy
what's he do on YouTube like what kind
of videos you make uh what about his
name oh really that's
big money on that stuff oh yeah
listen to me someone called the 911
Center and said with your name that you
wanted to hurt your family and hurt
yourself so we came to make sure you're
okay all right just listen to me okay I
am a popular streamer I am a YouTuber
okay come on I have 10 let me talk so
guess what okay okay good you may be out
of these cuffs but relax oh we're on
your side we're here to make sure you're
not going to harm yourself right all
right now people Knox people right oh
yeah yeah yeah all right let me talk let
me talk okay I am a popular streamer I
have 10 million Subs you know what a
streamer is right um sure I guess you
know what a streamer is yeah you ever
heard of a streamer SWAT or whatever
okay you got them toes on yeah
okay so tell us about the streamer
what'd you say I didn't say nothing were
you trying to be funny no I didn't do
nothing well apparently someone called a
help center out in Iowa and said
it's a dress and I want to kill myself
my family
is obviously a lie it's a lie we're here
to make sure right oh yes because of
school shootings right yeah be on my
side yeah work with me yeah yeah right
imagine if like you have a son imagine
you have a son you love him so much and
then someone calls your house and says
my son's they said you have a Glock an
AR-15 I want to shoot everybody oh s all
right well let's put you in the car and
then guess what us all right this is
just this is
they call somebody somebody called I
know y'all thinking
exactly exactly
I keep I just told him that
never exactly I keep telling I'm a thing
we're just trying to figure it out right
now I mean it's not really that much
exactly
this is prank I keep telling y'all
I can't really explain it to y'all
because I'm probably older but you know
it's just like I know what twitch is
Twitch YouTube
you know I'm famous you know and I'm
popular you know and and they're
probably upset jealous or something like
that no they're they're just trolls like
it's just common trolls well this was uh
I know but it's a card that's why we
gotta do our job
you as Mom
yes they prank our house all the time
well let us figure it out
no y'all taking my son over here
well we're gonna make sure everyone
doesn't want to harm us no no he ain't
gonna harm himself
people keep cranking my house well you
need to explain it to me so we can
investigate it properly please come here
I'm on your side I got five pounds
well because people were called saying
he wanted to kill you I don't know if
you knew that no but we didn't know that
yeah they called and said he had in the
gun and when it kills my mother he ain't
no guns
well come talk to us we can let him out
of cups
but because of school shootings we take
it seriously understanding he's not
about the key on my body because it's
constant pranks constant pranks hey
Sarge this is his mom and
surrounding my house right
now
can we do
a check and see what
people are famous
yeah
same thing same thing it's just what
um
we were worried about you don't say that
um
okay
okay 52-32 would you tell 54 47 and 45
to release our person in custody and
have him walk back this way
I knew you guys were three people that
knew what come to the bathroom
[Music]
it was a hotline and it said
right now
and I went down to the city officers
Chandler they
I'm about to kill my son I'm straight
what the fuck I know buddy just gotta do
our job yeah and what's she saying
what did my mama say
s
it's crazy
oh my God this is crazy dog
oh my gosh bro all right
I make sprints
it's a call okay I'm trying to explain
y'all y'all not y'all not getting what
I'm trying to say I am a popular
streamer this these these calls happen
all the time it just probably doesn't
happen in Cincinnati because there's not
that much famous people in Cincinnati
is it just people that are watching your
stream it's people watching my stream
that they're trolling they're just
trying to get me
like I said I am a pot I don't know it's
like I don't know I'm a popular streamer
I keep saying that
like like it's hard to me like it's hard
to like really explain like tell y'all
what's really going on
I can take anywhere in my house anywhere
I can show you exactly what I'm really
talking about
please
too hot for that today
so but it you need to understand it's
our job yeah and I get that but I'm
trying to explain to y'all bitch I keep
asking like why did it happening
what I'm trying to tell you is what was
said yes so what was said to us what's
that that there's someone yeah you and I
get that and I get control their entire
family
yes yes
this game I'm just a streamer game I
stream games
fortnite Battle Royale Apex just oh I'm
all around streaming
yeah
yeah it was just one of them
we just want a misunderstanding online
hey
but it was serious
you're not a block here IP address
assistant
[Music]
another thing like that to this address
we'll already have it documented this
has happened so that we know is it that
you ain't been spotted before right
maybe
it is
you guys are good
yeah sorry sorry I mean it's all good so
what do y'all breaking me and moving
forward besides yeah he's like proxy
servers and stuff to like hide his eyes
yeah it's all like your home address
yeah
it feels like it just happened like out
of nowhere I was just screaming friends
yeah yeah no thank you isn't the kid you
killed like didn't yes
because they said he was going to kill
him yeah there's a couple of them lately
that have happened this is ridiculous
we react but we don't over yeah
all right